There's something called a quantile and that's how you divide.
the
data in your distribution in some regions
You would do this for example to to know how much variance you
have the standard deviation of your probability
distribution distribution, and there are a number of ways the the
main three one of the following.
He can either divide them into four.
regions
That means we are using a quartile.
Okay, a quartile is one type of quantile.
There's another one called.
Decile, that's what you divide into 10 you can
get away. Usually with having four four is more than enough, but
if you have
like the first machine
That we looked at in our exercise where you have a lot of standard deviation. You
may want to divide your distribution into more regions
so you can start study them in more detail.
Then you have one called percentile.
Which divides the distribution into 100
regions?
by default
we will get the
the quartiles of the probability distribution
when you run the summary function
Okay, and this is telling you that the number 15.43
is the start of
the first quartile.
And then the median, is that
the median for this now.
Column is 19 Point 20.
And the third quartile is 22.8.
And if you want the mean for example instead of
just going to somewhere you can just type in mean.
And reference that same column.
to get the mean for
your data
this should not be a function.
Okay, so you don't have to actually calculate this by hand.
It's right there.
Then you have variance or VAR for short same thing. You
can just
throw in that
variable
Okay. So again empty cars refers to
the entire document.
If you can if you're imagining a an Excel sheet.
And what comes after the dollar sign is
corresponds to a column Within?
the document
okay.
So you want to know the variance?
Of that column again, you would use the four function
pass in that column as an argument.
Enter and that's the variance.
Now, of course, we know that the variance.
Is what we use to get to the standard
deviation. So for example, I can if you want to assign.
This variance to a variable you would say for example.
in
statistics we use Sigma squared to indicate
standard deviation.
So I will hear I would put Sigma 2.
And I assign it to variable and if you see here now, we have
a variable called Sigma 2 which corresponds to the variance if you want to know
standard deviation.
You take the square root of the variance. So you
would say Sigma.
Is the square root of Sigma?
squared
And that gives you the standard deviation.
There we go.
Of course, you don't have to do this. You can actually just go say SD.
And then pass in your reference.
That column to that day column.
And auto will give you the standard deviation just the same.
So these two numbers are equivalent.
Okay.
So variance is what you need to get to standard deviation, but
are still gives act it gives access
to both.